I leave on Sunday and yeah started doing
more like fight training and getting
more aggressive quite soon Kristen
Stewart dishes on the upcoming Charlie's
Angels reboot I've been boxing a little
bit which I've never done was like I'm
so addicted to it as soon as I have to
actually start sparring though and I
realize that what I'm doing is intended
to like fight people I'm like dude I
like it really is like assaulting and I
hate it I really hate it
but all I'm all I'm doing lately is
talking to Liz and can't wait to meet
the other girls and I leave on Sunday
and yeah started doing more like fight
training and getting more aggressive
quite soon Lucy Liu told us this is just
gonna be such a positive reboot to
happen for women of course why do you
think now is the right time and what can
you tease for us about what Elizabeth
Banks is bringing to it oh that's really
cool that you said that um it's true I
think that it's not not not maybe
everyone's immediate response that it
would be like something that we would
need to see again because the one that I
grew up with is so much fun and it's
like you know the reimagining is so
grounded and well intentioned and kind
of like really shows the way that women
can work together now and it sort of
tries it it tries to be warm and funny
but it lacks a Kitsch element but kind
of we've seen before which worked so
well we're not trying to sort of we're
not doing an impression of the last one
yeah I think liz is like so genuinely
naturally funny all the time anyway the
duo also talked their upcoming movie
Lizzie which hits theaters September
14th
you need me help yeah but not hard
enough you say that I am I'm so thrilled
and I can't believe what I'm strolling
over we really make that movie isn't
really coming out Kristen really in it I
mean it's just like something a passion
of mine I've had for years and years I
just wanted to know what may be the best
memory you guys will have from working
on this movie together is because it
seemed like you really bonded I think
our night at pinky masters dive-bar that
we really just got to like relax after
after our hard day's work and just kind
of chill and like the movie is so
restrained that we would be at work all
day just like even a down to wardrobe
everything was just like so tight
tightly bound so yeah going that was
like I would like talk about work the
whole time and then be like sorry it's
just like let's just hang out let's just
have a drink prefer to not do anything
what do you each like yeah and case do
got nostalgic as Twilight hits a major
milestone in November are you afraid no
does it feel like it's been ten years is
that wild to think about how beloved the
movie still is even 10 years later yeah
it's been a long time I don't know I
don't know how to it's honey I've also
lived in the same neighborhood for 10
years and I thought about that the other
day and I was like oh god I was like you
know a decade ago wasn't as crowded and
I was like that's bizarre to be able to
say that so same I mean just know
because you know certain things certain
memories you have will be close to you
forever it'll never be normal to say
that something was not long ago and I
feel that way about that - can we get a
cast reunion of any kind the fans would
love it yeah I'll call them up right now
bring them in and we can hold next
groups right now can we have that dream
do you how much do you guys all still
talk I'm I mean we all stay in touch a
bit yeah
you